مصر والناخبون الامريكيون الادلاء
باصواتهم في انحاء الولايات المتحده
لاختيار الكونجرس الجديد اضافه الى انتخاب
حكام معظم الولايات ومسؤوليها المحليين
وكذلك المجالس التشريعيه للولايات
[موسيقى]
معركه التجديد النصفي في الكونغرس
بالتحديد معني بها 35 مقعدا من مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ المئه وكل المقاعد الاربعمائه وال
135 في مجلس النواب
[موسيقى]
اخر الاستطلاعات الخاصه بمجلس الشيوخ تضعه
ست ولايات في خانه الولايات المتارجحه
بالنظر لتقارب مرشحي الحزبين فيها هذه
الولايات هي جورج وسوف
واذا حصل الجمهوريون على ثلاثه منها فيرجح
فوزهم بالاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
اما في مجلس النواب تنافس بين الحزبين في
نحو 34
للحزب الجمهوري في انتخابات مجلس النواب
والفوزي بما بين 10 و20 مقعدا ما يكفي
لحصوله على الاغلبيه
الرئيس الامريكي قال في تغريده ان لدى
الحزب الديمقراطي فرصه لاعاده بناء
الولايات المتحده بطريقه افضل للجميع
واضاف بيض النقل الجمهوريين يسعون لاعاده
البلاد الى الوراء على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
وقد ادلى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بصوته في مدينه في ولايه فلوريدا
وابدا ترامب تفائله بشان نتائج الانتخابات
مشيرا الى انها ستكون ليله عظيمه
للجمهوريين حسب تعبيره
واعلنت مفوضيه الانتخابات في مدينه
فيلادلفيا الواقعه في ولايه بنسلفانيا
الامريكيه انها قررت العوده الى العمل
باجراء يهدف الى الحد من احتساب الاصوات
بشكل مزدوج وذلك في اعقاب دعوه قضائيه
رفعها جمهوريون واقاله المفوضيه ان هذا
الاجراء سيتسبب في تاخير فرز الاف بطاقات
الاختراع ليله الثلاثاء في ولايه تشهد
منافسه شرسه بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
هذا وكشف مسؤول في اللجان الانتخابيه
التابعه لمدينه فلادلفيا الامريكيه في
ولايه بنسلفانيا احتمال الغاء نحوي ثلاثه
الاف و600 بطاقه اختراع عبر البريد واشار
المسؤول في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان
استبعاد بطاقات الاختراع المعنيه قد يتم
على خلفيه تضمنها معلومات غير صحيحه او
عدم استيفائها عددا من الشروط واضاف
المسؤول انه لا يزال بامكان الناخبين
الذين تم استبعاده بطاقتهم ان يدلو
باصواتهم عبر الحضور الى مراكز الاقتراع
اليوم
وكانت السلطات المحليه في ولايه اريزونا
قد اشارت الى وقوع اكثر من 18 حاله ترهيب
للناخبين على مدى الاسابيع الماضيه واعلن
مكتب سكرتيره ارينا ان حالات الترهيب
المسجله تم رصدها منذ بدء مرحله الاقتراع
المبكر في الثانيه عشر من تشرين الاول
اكتوبر الماضي واضاف انه جرى تحويله هذه
الشكاوى الى وكالات انفات القانون المحليه
والفيدراليه